great enemy Satan now
before Satan fell who was the highest
power in heaven take under the now
Godfather before samandphil
who was the next most powerful person
Lucifer
Ellen White writes in desire v I live by
who is 66 paragraph highest power in
hell writing about Lucifer she said God
made him good and beautiful as near as
possible she needs to listen
God made him good and beautiful as near
as possible like himself the closest
thing to God whether God the Father God
the Son God the Holy Ghost was Lucifer
now Ella white writes all should
understand that Satan was once an
exalted being his rebellion threw him
out of heaven but did not destroy his
power or make him a beast now when
Daniel prayed Daniel 9 and 10 for
understanding God st. Gabriel who took
Lucifer's place under the next most
powerful Gabriel Gabriel was held up by
Satan for how long
21 days now who made him human beautiful
can hold up the most powerful angel in
heaven Satan because Satan is still the
most powerful being after God you didn't
hear what I said listen close to you
Satan is still the most powerful being
in the universe after God so Gabriel
could not get past Satan the Bible say
Ella white write Bible Commentary volume
5 page 10 81 1083 paragraph 1 listen
carefully bear in mind it is only God
that can hold an
was Satan not Gabriel bear in mind that
it is only God that can hold an argument
with Satan now
if the high priest is limited he's less
than God are you listening to me
if the high priest is limited he is less
than God and a priest less than God can
not conquer Satan he has to be more
powerful than Satan and the only person
more powerful than Satan is God only
divine power can conquer Satan the high
priest cannot be limited now let me say
this Jesus is God and man as a man he
has limitations
he has voluntarily took in other words
he can't be everywhere at the same time
notice I said he has voluntarily took
but as God he is still all-powerful
notice what the Bible says about Jesus
in Hebrews 1 verse 3 listen carefully
who being the brightness of his glory
and the Express image of his person and
upholding all things by the word in his
power when he had by who these men
likeness of his glory so sins sat down
on the right hand of the Majesty on high
this purging of sins required his death
and his return from death now the Bible
says in Hebrews 2:14 that Jesus
destroyed him that had the power of
death that is the devil in coming back
from the dead Jesus showed his power
over Satan who had the power of death
you know the Bible says many times the
father is Jesus it is Jesus who raised
himself jesus said in John chapter 2
destroyed this body and in three days I
will raise it up he had to come back to
demonstrate he had total power over
Satan the high priest is without limit a
limited Savior can
not save you whoever that Minister is
may God correct him but he's wrong okay
there are some questions regarding
salvation by works and I would like to
combine all of those in just one
question would I be saved if I'm not a
vegetarian would I be saved if I cook on
Sabbath would I be saved if I cook for
those who are needy okay if I cook on
Sabbath well let me come closer
will I be saved if you read Exodus 16
verse 26 to 30 God told ears lights see
what he shall see today cook on the
preparation day because tomorrow in the
next days the sabbath loi tells us there
is to be no cooking on sabbath but the
bible said that she does say you may
warm the food no cooking on sabbath now
the question is will I go to heaven or
hell if I cook on Sabbath people are
lost for disobeying God we are lost for
disobeying God God tortillas lights the
food you prepare on Friday will remain
fresh on Sabbath because there's to be
no cooking on Sabbath and the food
remain fresh God is the same uh-huh
uh-huh can you keep your food fresh on
Sabbath if you're cooking on Friday yes
there's to be no cooking on Sabbath next
question how about being vegetarian
would I be saved if I'm not a vegetarian
will I be saved if I'm not a vegetarian
you will be saved if you ignore God's
conviction regarding your health habits
if God has given you light that meat is
you continue to eat it you have
condemned yourself are you with me you
here's what John 3:19 says and this is
the condemnation that in light is coming
to the world now has the world received
light regarding diet yes or no yes you
talk to any medical association the
Heart Association the Cancer Association
they in their recommendations for diet
they tell you either cut out meat or
reduce it drastically because meat was
not originally God's plan for us Genesis
1:29 and God said behold I have given
given you every herb bearing seed which
is upon the face of all the earth and
every tree in the which is the fruit of
a tree yielding seed to you it shall be
for me even for the animals they were to
eat vegetarian a meal now Ellen White
right I don't recall where God allowed
sinners to eat meat to shorten their
lives he allowed them to eat meat to
shorten their lives let me ask you this
if you plant a seed in the ground after
a few days what happens
it grows if you plant a chicken leg in
the ground after a few days what happens
nothing worms now when we plant things
in our stomach you plant seeds they
reduce life you plant dead flesh nothing
it was never God's will that we eat meat
god's preferences of vegetarian diet and
if he convicts you and you resist the
conviction you have condemned yourself
not God you by your choice something to
do with food again this is the last
about food bread rain no more question
two
get in because there is are too many
accidentally I ate pork is it a sin or
not you mean accidentally you enter
alright that's not a sin yeah that's not
a sin acts 17:30 the times of this
ignorance God winked sad when you don't
know God is not gonna so merciful when
you don't know he does not condemn you
but he arranges circumstances to bring
the light of your error to your
knowledge because even though you did it
ignorantly it was still wrong I didn't
say that clearly let me say it
differently an ignorant sin is still a
sin and it does damage but God does not
condemn you because you don't know
listen to me again an ignorant sin is
still a sin okay but God and His mercy
does not condemn the ignorant person but
it is still a sin and it hurt you if you
smoke not knowing it is wrong it will
damage your lungs now God won't condemn
you because you don't know but your
lungs are still damaged and when you
come to Christ you may have to have a
lung removed but you're forgiven sin
ignorant or willful is still sin but if
you add that pork really ignorantly God
does not condemn you but now that you
know still tell him you're sorry there's
nothing wrong with confession okay the
next question for after that is if I'm
given a abominable food let's say pork
is it okay to give it away to my
neighbor alright if I'm given an
abominable food like pork yeah porks not
the only abominable food but we keep
picking on pork okay if it's bad for you
it's bad for your neighbor if God can
fix you take off your jewelry don't give
it to your neighbor are you
do what Jacob did when his people took
off the jewelry they barely dentistry
get rid of it somehow if it's sinful it
is sinful no matter who puts it on or no
matter who eats it so if someone gives
you a pork you can't eat it don't give
it to someone so the person does wrong
get rid of it somehow okay this is a
very relevant question all of us I had
been baptized but I keep on sinning you
keep on swimming like drinking because
as he I don't know if he's a boy or a
girl but all right he feels so high a
socially high with somebody else who are
drinking that's why he could not resist
the so I've been baptized I keep
drinking and whatever else all right
baptism is an outward symbol of death to
a past life notice I said death not a
coma in order coma is you know what
unconsciousness is a lot of people are
baptized in a state of unconsciousness
not death you must be dead to your past
life that's why you are bury are you
with me the life must be given entirely
to God when that happens God accepts
that life as his own and he has the
legal right to work in your life many of
us we surrender ourselves to God
partially going down in a baptismal pool
getting wet does not change your life it
is the change that occurs in your heart
and so for this person if you're still
drinking and smoking and whatever you're
doing you need to re-examine your
surrender to God you read the New
Testament Jesus said thou shalt love the
Lord thy God with all thy heart with all
thy soul with all thy mind with all thy
strength with all thy might you also
find it in Deuteronomy 6 verse 46
it must be total sum
now even with a total surrender you are
growing and you will slip but sin will
not be a lifestyle if sin is still a
lifestyle you have to review was I truly
surrendered to God because the Bible
says all things are passed away all
things are become new okay this no
questions are about second coming of
Christ
the first question saying the why are
the seventh-day Adventists are believing
on the second coming of Christ I wonder
if that's a seventh-day Adventist who
was that question why do we believe in
the second coming of Christ it is the
most popular doctrine in the Bible
especially in the New Testament the
second coming of Christ is hinted at all
the way in genesis 3:15 and i will put
in let me pray again father please
continue to give me wisdom there god
please before i rush off in my old
carnal way give me wisdom father in
jesus name amen
genesis 3:15 and i will put enmity
between thee and the woman between thy
seed and her seed it shall bruise thy
head and thou shalt bruise his heel now
this is the first mention of the gospel
on the earth it also includes the second
coming of Christ and you say to me how
do you say that baura Romans chapter 16
quickly Romans 16 Romans 16 the question
was why do Adventist preach about the
second coming if there's no second
coming there's no point for all this
church and vegetarian lifestyle and
following Jesus and there's no second
coming why did Christ die where's the
time the Second Coming is part of the
overall atonement of Jesus Christ
do you have Romans 16 verse 20 if you
have my version read it for me what is
verse 20 say and the God of peace shall
bruise Satan
under your heel or feet shortly now what
does that sound like genesis 3:15 now
Paul is writing this after Jesus went
back to heaven are you with me and he's
saying now the Lord of things shall or
will there is a future crushing of the
head that still has to occur at Calvary
the head was crushed yes but I'm told if
you kill a cockroach for many hours is
still alive Satan is the greatest
cockroach in the history of the world so
he's still alive you see Christ is
coming back to finish him off that's the
second coming the Lord of peace will
bruise Satan under your feet we will be
part of that final blow that puts an end
to Satan we must preach the Second
Coming let me tell you something about
the second coming also Jesus died to
deliver us from the power of sin that
power that leads us to drink and curse
and smoke and covet and whatever else he
died to deliver us from the penalty of
sin which is death he also died to
deliver us from the presence of sin even
though you converted you're living a
sinless life all around you you see sin
that has to be dealt with and so the
entire work of atonement will not end
until the end of the thousand years when
this world is made all over Satan
destroyed all sinners destroyed and a
brand new world starts that marks the
end just the way as a seal when he was
cast out into the wilderness marked the
end of the Day of Atonement we must
preach the second coming of Christ Jesus
said let not your heart be troubled
he believed in God believe also in me in
my father's house are many mansions if
it were not so I would have told you I
go to prepare a place for you and if I
go and prepare a place for you I will
come again there's another reason but
Jesus has to come back follow me closely
God does not lie practice one verse two
numbers 23:19 Jesus says I am truth John
14:6 Deuteronomy 32 first for the father
truth first John 5:6 the holy ghost says
truth Father Son and Holy Ghost are all
truth they don't lie now Jesus said I'm
coming back but long before Jesus said
that on earth he told Abraham he would
give him the land of Canaan am i right
yes or no yes go to Hebrews 11 Hebrews
11 hundreds of hundreds of years past
God told Abraham you and your seed will
inherit this lab go to Hebrews 11 let's
read verse 13 if you have my version
read for me what does that say these all
died in faith
meaning Abraham Isaac Jacob Sarah
Rebecca and Rachel these all died in
faith come on not having received the
promises but having seen them afar off
and were persuaded of them and embraced
them and confessed there were strangers
and pilgrims on the earth now Abraham
died when Abraham died did he possess
the land of Canaan yes or no no did God
tell him he'd have it yes did Abraham
die without receiving that land yes did
God lie no so what does God have to do
come back and raise him up to keep his
word ah you all missed it you missed it
you had a good meal so you're sleeping
okay God told Abraham I'll give you this
land when Abraham had to bury Sarah you
know what he had to do buy a cave
because the land was not his he had to
buy a cave from the Hittites God has to
come back
raise up Abraham in order to keep his
word that also tells us another very
very lovely story about God not even
death can keep God's Word from being
fulfilled not even death God will raise
you from the death to keep his word okay
must come back we
reach the second coming the next
question is about just provide the pecks
to answer the question who shall come is
it the father or the son yeah in the
second coming the Bible says when the
Son of man shall come in his glory and
all the holy angels with him now when
Jesus came down on Sinai the father and
the son came then ly tis very clear both
came down on Sinai but it was Jesus that
did all the speaking when Jesus the
Bible says in revelation 8 verse 1 and
we need opened the Seventh Seal There
was silence in heaven about a space of
half an hour why is this silence in
heaven everybody is coming now keep in
mind the most precious beings in the
worlds of Christ other sinners he saved
you didn't hear what I said are the
angels in heaven who never sinned angels
in heaven that have never sinned yes we
are closer to Christ than they are the
most precious possession Christ has is
us when he comes for us everybody is
coming don't miss it do not miss it
next question yes pastor I have a
question asking some advice now as we
know there are a number of people in our
church that are following this idea that
the Holy Spirit is not God now when we
find out that one of our fellow
ministers has this kind of idea how
should we deal with it after you well
okay and then they say and then they
they refuse uh-huh and yet still they
continue to say it's a serious problem
my brother Matthew 18 gives us how to
deal with someone who offends you you go
to the person one-on-one there's no
result you take someone with you there's
no result you go to the church now you
cannot throw out a minister the
conference has to do that
you take the steps the Bible lays out
you go to the elders as the elders to
speak to the pastor if there's no
success
you let the pastor know we have to go to
the conference do nothing behind his
back that's not the way God functions
but to deny the Holy Spirit is a serious
crime
the Bible says wherefore I say into you
all manner of sin and blasphemy shall be
forgiven unto men but the blasphemy
against the Holy Ghost shall not be
forgiven whosoever therefore shall speak
a word against the Son of God it shall
be forgiven him but whoso speaketh
against the Holy Ghost it shall not be
forgiven him neither in this world
neither in the world to come
Matthew 12 31 and 32 32 yes if that
Minister is preaching the Holy Spirit is
not divine is less than a divine being
someone needs to talk to him because if
you believe the Holy Spirit is less than
then you are in spiritual trouble it is
because of the Holy Spirit in your life
did you and I are able to resist the
attacks of the enemy listen to what
elamite writes in evangelism pit 617
paragraph 2 the Prince of the power of
evil can only be held in check by the
power of God in the third person of the
Godhead the Holy Spirit he didn't know
what I said the Prince of the power of
darkness or evil who is that Satan can
only be held in check by the power of
God in the third person of the Godhead
the Holy Spirit now she also writes in
testimonies volume 1 page 341 paragraph
1 God alone can limit the power of Satan
she writes in testimonies volume 5 page
448 paragraph 2 Jesus can limit the
power of Satan you put those three
quotations together only Father Son and
Holy Ghost can control the devil
all three all three it is dangerous to
lower the holy spirit dangerous let me
talk about the holy spirit some more I
like to talk about the holy spirit go to
first Corinthians to first Corinthians -
if you don't believe the Holy Spirit is
divine just keep it to yourself don't
corrupt other people please
first Corinthians - do you have that let
me pray father as I deal with this most
important subject give me simple
language I pray in Jesus name Amen
read verse 9 uh-huh
I have not seen nor ear heard neither
have entered into the heart of man the
things which God has prepared for them
that love now carefully next verse but
it was housed by his spirit for the
spirit searcheth all things yea now
listen the 1st Corinthians 2 verse 10
this the he the Greek word search it
means to understand to a very deep level
just understand completely now the
spirit searcheth understands how many
things all things but what all things
have ease the deep things of God you
know that means everything God knows
finish my words the Holy Spirit knows
you have to be God
only someone equal with God can know
everything God knows now let's go to
John chapter 3 John 3 let's read verse 8
very familiar verse you have that
anybody read nice and loud well go ahead
my brother the wind blows
Ritt listeth uh-huh and now here is the
sound thereof does not tell whence it
cometh and whither it goeth finish
carefully now so it's every one that is
born of the Spirit now what you
understand by born of the Spirit what is
that the new birth give me another word
conversion give me another word
justification it is done by the spirit
now but I see a 45 if the Spirit is the
one who does that
Isaiah 45 read verse 22 Isaiah 45 but
someone else beside my handsome brother
should be looking for it read my brother
pastor here's our faithful brother to
read look unto me o come to me and be
saved all the ends of the earth for I am
God and there is none else according to
that verse who saves God according to
John 3:8 from the lips of Jesus who
converts the Holy Spirit the Holy Spirit
must be God okay that's very clear
all right I mean the Holy Spirit
question to the Holy Spirit please
explain the two reigns who say the
Torrance the first and the last strain
the early and the latter ranges of the
Holy Spirit huh what about explain oh oh
in the Old Testament the Jews had the
early rain to get the crop to grow and
the latter rain to write me to maturity
are you following me rain so I just
spring up rain to bring it ready for
harvest the spiritual application of
that is that we are God's harvest where
God's crop growing in Christ we received
the Holy Ghost to get us growing but God
will pour out them latter rain so that
this work of the gospel may be completed
by those who have grown and benefited
from the early rain let me say that
again those
have benefited from the early rain and
have been faithful in what they know
will receive the latter rain which is an
outpouring of the Holy Spirit which will
result in powerful preaching and
miracles performed at Pentecost that was
not the latter rain that was the early
rain but it gives us an idea of what
will it will be like when the latter
rain falls
you know the powerful work those
apostles did under the power of the
early rain which is the Holy Ghost the
latter rain is the same Holy Ghost but
greater power because now the entire
work will be brought to an end but only
those who have taken hold of the early
rain by living OB talita God will
receive the latter rain and let me tell
you some people are receiving the latter
rain individually before it is poured
out on the church as a body even as some
people's probation closed every day
before there's a global close of
probation and white rice by the way
every day every hour
someone's probation is closing and if
that doesn't make you somber and solemn
and think I don't know what will
yes pastor so I don't know if this is
the finale question but the question
goes like this as it's the a what are
the doctrines and Bible texts that we
should know by heart that's a good
question
when I was here when I became an
Adventist when I was a little boy long
ago we were given Bible for system
memorize we call them Adventist verses
revelation 14:6 to 12 revelation 12:17
revelation 22:12 and 14
did I say revelation 12:17 revelation 18
one two five
you have to know John 14 one two three
isaiah eight verse 20 we were given
several Bible verses that we just had to
Oh plus some quotations from Ellen White
higher than the highest human fortune
reads is God's ideal for his children
godliness
God likeness is the goal to be reached
our ideas of Education take to Nora and
to low arrange all these quotations we
had to learn and so those are some of
the Bible verses that were given to us
plus of course Daniel 8:14 we had to
know how to explain the 23 and I
remember going through it date by day
fact by fact practicing how to explain
the 2300 by the way that's what your
first witnesses do they assemble in
their churches and they are taught they
are drilled how to present what they
believe we don't and so our people are
just tossed over because they cannot
defend the basic teachings of this
church by the way I have a question of
my own what are the five foundational
teachings of this church we call them
the pillar of the church what are they
the Sabbath they all start with s the
Sabbath the sanctuary Second Coming
spirit of prophecy state of the Dead
those are the five we call them the
pillars know how to defend them if you
are a set of the Adventist study them
let me say something else there is a
very simple book and I wanted to
recommend it to my good brother Joseph
it's called Bible readings for the home
it is laid out just like the Catholic
catechism question-answer the Catholics
know how to teach their people question
answer question answer this book has the
same style question answer it is simple
you study it like a textbook you'll be
able to defend truth find it get it
Bible readings for the home all the
subjects you want that we believe that
the Bible teaches it's not just we
believe the Bible teaches them all right
next question okay these are the last
three different questions the first is
where will God put his kingdom in the
last day sinigang where will God put his
kingdom in the last day we will go well
where will get establish his
kingdom we really establish his kingdom
in the last last days now when Jesus
stood before Pilate in John 18 jesus
said My Kingdom is not of this world if
my kingdom were of this world then would
my servants fight that I should not be
delivered unto you but now is my kingdom
not from hence the kingdom of God
physically is not of this world
spiritually it's in us are you with me
listen to me carefully there was a time
when the kingdom of God was on the earth
in the nation of Israel when the last
Israelite King was destroyed they was
Anna kaya God no longer had a kingdom on
the earth so Jesus says the kingdom of
God is within you
Christ says my kingdom is coming if all
palate is not of this earth when he
comes he will reestablish a physical
Kingdom but for now the kingdom of God
dwells in us when the principles of the
kingdom are in our hearts and lives the
principles of the kingdom which are the
10 commandments of God when God called
the issue eyes out of Egypt he only gave
them the Ten Commandments that's all he
wanted because of disobedience and
weakness he gave them everything else a
lot of other thing listen to what Ella
white writes the attraction prophets
pain 364 paragraph 2 listen very
carefully if man had kept the law of God
as given to Adam after his fall preserve
by Noah and observed by Abraham there
would have been no necessity for assert
the ordinance of circumcision and if the
descendants of Abraham had kept the
Covenant of which circumcision was a
sign they would never have been seduced
into idolatry neither would it have been
necessary for them to suffer a life of
bondage in Egypt they would have kept
God's law in mind and there would have
been no necessity for it to be engraved
on the tables of stone or proclaimed
from our Sinai and if the people had
kept the Ten Commandments
there would have been no need for the
other directions given to Moses all God
wants from us really is the Ten
Commandments in our lives as living
principles of love alright pastor
another question pastor which is very
common is every time a person died he
would always say my father or my mother
is already in heaven uh-huh
even Adventists would post on Facebook
telling them that my father just went to
heaven because they're dead so how do we
enlighten that's one of the cardinal
teachings of the church
dead people are in the grave I all right
let me let me be patient it's a virtue
what the Genesis - please Genesis - do
you have a little pulpit I can put my
but there's no little pulpit right here
I can put my Bible on no no no can I
have that chair please and God bless you
for your decision god bless you God
bless you God bless you God bless you
all right do we have Genesis - let me
pray father I'm discussing where people
go after death this was the devil this
continues to be one of the false
doctrines the devil uses to deceive the
whole world give me a simple explanation
I pray in Jesus name Amen
Genesis - let's read verse 7 what does
that say and the Lord God formed man of
the dust of the ground breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life and man
became what a living soul now from what
was Adam made the dust of the ground is
that clear
go to verse 19 read with me and out of
the ground the Lord God formed every
beast of the earth and every fowl of the
air and brought them unto Adam to see
what he would call them and whatsoever
Adam called every living creature that
was the name thereof salamat solana my
good brother god bless you thank you so
much
good ma'am all right question for you
from what was Adam made from what where
the animals made dust okay are you with
me dust go to Ecclesiastes chapter 3
verse 19 listen very carefully if you're
certainly after this even if you're not
listen carefully Ecclesiastes 3 reading
verse 19 read with me for that which we
fall if the sons of men befall if be
stopped
what does the word befalleth mean to
happen to men the Bible says what
happens to us happens to animals
keep reading even even one thing before
we follow him the same thing keep
reading as the one diet so diet the
other stop at the physical level we die
the way animals die the Bible says is
one death read the next statement
carefully yay they have all one breath
the breath of life in me is the breath
of life in a dog I said at the physical
level are you following me finish the
verse now saw that a man hath no
preeminence above above a beast if you
go to a cemetery for pets and you dig up
one of the graves what will you find
come on dust and bones
if you dig up a cemetery for human
beings what will you find dust and bones
because the Bible says they have the
same flesh they have the same breath
they die the same way now first twenty
all go and to one place come on all out
of the dust all turn to dust again now
what
then what does the Bible say all go
where one place where's that now this is
the root of the truth of where the dead
go when they die if you say a dead man
goes to heaven you also have to say his
dead dog goes with him because the Bible
says they go away the same place read
verse 21 now carefully
kouno if this man of man that goeth
upward and the spirit of it goeth how
can you say the Bible say a man at death
goes up and an animal goes down how can
you say that the Bible says they go the
same place now there is a reason for
that and we find it of course in the
first three chapters of Genesis go to
Genesis 3 we're looking at the root of
this teaching Genesis 3 you have Genesis
3 let's read from verse 17 animus sinned
following his wife God deals with a wife
in verse 16 now he talks to Adam is
everyone listening verse 17 read with me
and unto Adam he said because thou hast
hearkened unto the voice of thy wife and
has eaten of the tree of which I
commanded thee saying thou shalt not eat
of it cursed is the ground for thy sake
keep winning in sorrow shalt thou eat of
it all the days of thy life keep winning
forms also on fizzles shall it bring
forth unto thee and thou shalt eat the
herb of the field first my team in the
sweat of thy face shalt thou eat bread
come on till thou walk return unto the
ground give reading for out of it was
now taken key reading for dust thou art
and unto dust shalt thou return now
think with me when God is talking to
Adam is
alive yes or no yes what does God call
him what does God call him look at verse
19 dust he calls him dust now 4:7 says
of chapter 2 just listen and the Lord
God formed man of the dust of the ground
breathed into his nostrils the breath of
life man became a living soul listen to
me carefully
Adam was not made from dust and breath
he was made from dust the breath brought
the dust of life listen to me again Adam
was made from dust so when God is
talking to him God doesn't see dust and
breath thou art he just says dust thou
art and unto dust shalt thou return now
we have a principle it is called the
principle of return now how could God
tell Adam till thou return until the
dust how can God say that now tomorrow I
am returning to United States that's
breaking from how many of you have ever
been to Bangladesh can I see your ham
Bangladesh I have been there so I can
return are you following me I can return
why does God tell Adam until thou return
unto the ground what does it mean by
that that's where you came from
and when you die finish my words that's
where you go now God made Adam from dust
where did God find the dust on the earth
where did the breath come from why can
Adam not go back to heaven or go to
heaven that's not where you're rich
that's not where he came from there's no
dust in heaven he came from the dust now
if he had been made of brass ah he could
have gone back no he was made from dirt
so he has to go back are you following
me yes
go to Genesis 18 listen to Abraham
Genesis 18
we read from first 25 Genesis 18 reading
for verse 25 do you have that let me
pray father in heaven I am still
explaining this very very vital subject
speak through me to God in Jesus name I
pray amen read for me was si that be far
from thee to one destroy to do after
this manner to the slow the wicked the
righteous with the wicked and that the
righteous should be as the wicked
Abraham is telling God you cannot
destroy the righteous with the wicked
that be far from thee shall not the
judge of all the earth they were right
and the Lord said if I fight in Sodom 45
I will do what I will not destroy it
first 27 read for me and Abraham
answered the Lord and said what behold I
have taken upon me to speak into the
Lord now how does he describe himself
which am but dust and ashes that's all I
am he does not say I am dustin breath go
to Psalm 103 Psalm 103 I hope you're
listening I really do
Psalm 103 you have that let's read verse
14 let's read 13 and 14 are you there
read with me like as a father pities his
children so the Lord pities them that
fear him now read verse 14 carefully for
he knows our frame that was how we were
made he remembers that we are
not that we're dust and breath so over
and over we read we are dust and God's
principle is you go back to where you
came from
now no matter what you read in Luke
about Lazarus in Richmond you have to
stick with this foundation which is the
dead go back to where they came from
Luke cannot preach something different
from that I said all of that to say any
Adventist will know when you die you're
in the grave
just like Jesus the Bible says David is
not ascended into heaven his Sepulchre
is still with us he's in the grave if
you were in heaven there was no need for
Christ to come back are you following me
to raise the dead
because they're already alive it is
there are two doctrines false the devil
uses to deceive most of the world
doctrine one the first day of the week
is holy doctrine two dead people are not
really dead - he uses to deceive the
whole world next question when do I stop
yes my question all right go ahead we
started at about 2:30 is 10:00 to 4:00
we stopped at 4 o'clock 10:00 whoa -
these questions are not related with
each other so I don't know pastor if the
10 minutes would suffice to give us the
home for that if we do not know the
answer we might be same what I mean is
whether we answer it or not whether we
may know the answer or that we may not
know the answer we can still be saved
there are still four questions that are
not related that I'm I think not suffice
let me have one of them okay okay if he
said that I know Elijah and Moses had
been to heaven but by some parts of the
Bible is saying that nobody gets into
heaven so how would you like to make it
one is going to have them among says
Elijah and I know yes they are all in
heaven but there are some
part of the Bible text that is saying
that nobody had been into heaven go to
John 3 ok John 3 they don't understand
well let me not say that
let me not let me just answer the
question and forget what I don't
understand John 3 let's read verse 12 of
John 3 let's read from a level of John 3
we have 10 minutes left
questions keep coming okay give the mic
to my brother okay we're reading John 3
from verse 11 verily verily I say to you
we speak that we do know that's right
let's divide that we have seen aha this
is Jesus is saying and talk about what I
know what I've seen
keep reading and he received that's
right meaning Jesus the Holy Spirit the
father whomever he is saying I am
telling you what I have seen and you
don't believe me now keep reading if I
if I have told you earthly things aha he
believed not yes how shall we believe if
I tell you pause Jesus is saying if I
tell you about things on the earth where
you live and you don't believe me how
will you believe me if I tell you about
things in heaven keep reading now and no
man
aha but he that came down from him ah
that's the clue he that came down what
is he saying no one has gone up and come
down to report yes the Son of Man
originated in heaven well not originated
that's his home he has come down but
when elijah went up he didn't come down
and tell the people what he saw when
Moses went up he did not come down and
tell the people what he saw when I was
the other fellow Enoch went up he did
not come down so what the Bible mean no
one has gone up and come down to report
but Jesus has come down to report amen
you must read the Bible microscopically
well said pastor alright nice question
when Adam and Eve ate that forbidden
fruit how come that they did not die
immediately
why didn't they die immediately the
Bible says there is a mediator between
God and man the instant now revelation
13:8 says and all that dwell upon the
earth shall worship Him whose names are
not written in the book of life of the
lamb slain from the foundation of the
world in a fairy my love's a strange but
in a very remarkable way even before
Jesus shed his blood his blood was
affected by faith it is because he's the
lamb slain from the foundation of the
world that Adam and Eve were not killed
immediately as soon as this sin Jesus
sent him as a mediator and his blood
save them he actually died four thousand
years later but Christ is the lamb the
blood of Christ is not covered Adam and
Eve by faith it is the blood of Christ
that covered Abraham and Noah and Enoch
and Adam there's only one way to be
saved the blood of Jesus when he came to
the earth he actually shed the blood
physically but my faith his blood was
effective way back mm-hmm because no one
can be saved without the blood of Jesus
Christ which represents his life next
question pastor I think this is very
this is the nail to the coffin okay John
why did they bid was called the man
after God's own heart
despite his scenes of murder and
adultery Syrian why why did they bid was
called the man after his after cuts on
her yes this might all be scenes
uh-huh adultery and murder yes make it
relevant all of us Syrian make it
relevant all of us
right if you listen to some ad with his
talking about David
you would think Dave his whole life all
he did was commit adultery and commit
murder
you know the Bible actually says that
David offended God in his affair with
Bathsheba that's the thing the Bible
identifies as David's big mistake
David's life was not a life of
disobedience to God there are the forces
that say that Solomon did not obey David
his heart was not perfect with God as
was the heart of his father David and
when David realized he was wrong what
did he do he repented he was broken but
David's life was not a life of adultery
and fornication it was a life of warfare
but not adultery and murder No he made
that mistake yes it was a double mistake
in the same event God forgave him he
paid his price he loved God more than
anything else he was a man after God's
own heart he loved God more than he
loved himself Solomon built the
tabernacle but David gathered all the
materials he just wanted to give God
everything he could read the Psalms and
see how much David loved God he made a
big mistake
Moses loved God he made one big mistake
just before entering Canaan
the Lord said go up to that mountain and
die David was a man after God's own
heart Abraham was called the friend of
God and he committed adultery with Hagar
but you can it is a difference between a
sin and a life of sin are you with me
now you're not with me there is a
difference between a sin and a life of
sin as you grow in Christ you'll make
mistakes but your mistakes will become
fewer and fewer and fewer and you won't
keep making the same mistake David
wasn't mad Jesus will sit on the throne
of his father David when he comes and if
we can live a life like David we'll be
living powerful lives all right it's
four o'clock on the dot let me thank you
for your questions let me urge you as
your brother please how do you say
please in Tagalog huh
what well that's too long okay
please please what am I about to say I'm
holding the Bible and I'm saying please
what am I about to say
read your Bible study it for God's sake
study your Bible learn about Jesus for
yourself when you stand in the judgment
you cannot tell God the pastor did not
preach good sermons God holds you
responsible for knowing this why Jesus
said in John 16:13 howbeit when he the
Spirit of Truth has come he will guide
you into all truth
the Spirit is sent to us to teach those
who are trying but remember what Jesus
said blessed are they which do hunger
and thirst after righteousness finish
the promise they shall be filled
do you hunger and thirst after Bible
knowledge don't answer me do you hunger
and thirst for a knowledge of God's Word
the possible answer is no are you a nice
person
yes are you decent yes do you love the
church yes are you a vegetarian maybe do
you hunger thirst for the Word of God No
a person who hungers and thirst for
righteousness will spend time in this
you're not saved by being decent
although all salespeople will be decent
you are saved by allowing the Word of
God to work in your life and you have to
know it in order to know Jesus you
cannot know Jesus if you don't know the
Bible you can know about Jesus every
atheist knows about Jesus but to know
Jesus you've got to study the Word of
God I plead with you make time for God's
Word
please let's stand and pray before I
pray any prayer requests just raise your
hand dr. Jim yes pray for the newly
baptized members the devil will try to
turn them around we have to pray and
pray and pray without ceasing someone
else prayer requests yes my brother your
brother's your mother and sister to give
their lives to Christ and walk in the
truth and the truth itself is light okay
and life pray for those who are blessing
to us in so many ways yes and many
people have been a blessing to me and I
pray for them every day my commitment is
to pray for them until Jesus comes when
they no longer need prayer prayer
requests yes pastor the elder of the
church is sick and Astacio where god
knows the whole name it's ok Anastasio
he is sick the elder of which church
okay under now all right Anastasio is
sick he's lead of the church all right
pray for him someone else prayer request
yes
pray for what church building okay all
right church building by the way if the
church building is not complete
you should not beautify your house take
care of the church first then take care
you I'm not talking to you uptown to all
of us listen to me carefully you don't
believe me read Haggai chapter 1 if
God's church is incomplete
don't keep beautifying yours finish
God's house then work on yours mm-hmm
somebody else prayer request okay oh yes
what you say oh yes pray for the
students who are here their studies God
will provide the needs bless the
appearance to keep providing for them
keep them upright and the leaders of AUP
mm-hmm anything else those with an
interest in Bible study prayer for them
yes I have a request pray for me
anytime I come across your mind just say
Lord wherever that man is put your words
in his mouth and I meet that very very
seriously did I see your hand your
education tuition and all students can
identify with that tuition mm-hmm hi
chapter 2 verse 8 the silver is mine and
the gold is mine
Psalm 24 verse 1 the earth is the Lord's
and the fullness thereof anything else
all right let's bow our heads our Father
in heaven thank you for this question
and answer session I hope I spoke your
words I tried I hope your sons your
daughters learn something they God
I hope they will leave this place with a
renewed determination to study a word
and to know it for themselves God let
your word be more vital to them than
food as job said I have esteemed the
words of his mouth more than my
necessary food as jeremiah said the
words were found and I did eat them as
Jesus said I have meat to eat you know
not of Lord give us a love for your word
because as your word dwells in us it
removes our interest in the world
remember all the prayer requests that
were offered for tuition a pastor an
elder whose sake a church building
education family members outside the
church whatever the request is they God
you are a generous God you're not
willing that any should perish
you give lavishly because the entire
universe is yours answer us in the areas
our need father a double blessing on the
students help them to figure out clearly
how they will use the education for your
glory bless AUP let the leaders at
Minnesota schools so that it becomes a
light to this community and leads many
people to Christ continue to use me
wherever I go
bless the Philippines bless every
country represented by this congregation
take God when you come save all of us
without losing one along with those for
whom we have labored I pray in Jesus
name let God's people say Amen and amen
god bless you god bless you Pastor skip
in behalf of south-central Eastern
Conference the president of the south
central Eastern Conference conveying his
gratitude for your presence and also to
you dr. Jimmy let's all rise for the
closing song hello hello
let's sing over the sunset mountain do
you know that song anybody who can play
the piano
over the sunset Mountain releasing over
the sunset mountain someday our safely
go into the arms of Jesus
Allu heart love me so
all over the sunset Montaigne heaven
awaits for me over - sunset Martin Jesus
my Savior
shadows will
[Music]
Saros
oh what a wonderful day
/ decide
[Music]
waits for me oh Jesus my say your I'll
see it's off our heads our most gracious
loving Heavenly Father we thank you so
much Oh God and we praise you for your
wonderful works that you have done to
our lives thank you O God for
enlightening us with your words
thank you for God for using pastor Randy
to provide us your truths to guide us O
God that we may learn to have love for
the Bible for your truths we pray ler
that each one of us as we depart from
this place will not by new zeal and a
desire to fully understand you and to
unto and to read your words and to spend
time knowing you Lord that when the time
comes we will all be ready to be with
you there in the heavenly home it's the
was prepared for us Heavenly Father we
ask for your holy angels that excel in
strength to provide safety as we travel
as we go to our respective homes may
your Holy Spirit Lord continue to use us
that even as we depart from this place
we can be witnesses we can be disciples
of yours wherever we go we answered for
the forgiveness of our sins in Jesus
name we pray amen
happy Sabbath everyone and have a good
day
you